thanks so much for chatting with us
today oh no pleasure
shoe music legend and almost everyone in
the world knows her songs did you feel a
big responsibility telling her story
through this movie yeah 100 I was
extremely um
I was extremely aware of uh
how it was my goal to to hold on to her
Integrity during this so I think it's it
was part of my job in this and to make
sure that
um
we dealt with her life as sensitively as
possible
um and from a place of real love for her
um and yeah there was a huge
responsibility but you know and that was
really scary but I I look back on it now
and I'm glad I I took that on
you play with Whitney from when she was
a teenager up until her death at age 48.
how did you handle that challenge of
Aging yeah it was it was quite
interesting because early on we decided
not to do any of the kind of go down the
prosthetic route and and all of that
because it felt like um
a little in this in this context a
little heavy-handed
um so it was really about for me the big
marker that I had to work on because
hair and costume beautifully were
arranged by by
um the people we had uh but for me it
was about vocal tone you know
um if you kind of jump from the
interviews that Whitney did at 19 to
some of the interviews she did at let's
say like you know 45
is a big difference you know naturally
you age but also there is like a kind of
raspiness
um to her voice
um that I wanted to to try and Achieve
um at least a little bit so we got
understanding that she's aging but also
there may be some vocal damage that's
happening
um because of how much he's working but
also because of her lifestyle
um so yeah it was it was a challenge but
it was again something that was really
fascinating to me
um and something I wanted to achieve
technically to to allow the audience to
suspend their disbelief for the duration
of the film
um last question really goodly and would
you ever consider exploring a singing
career in the future like JLo did after
Athena because your vocals have been
raised by everyone in the past thank you
absolutely not no no
thank you though well it was absolutely
you were just incredible I enjoyed every
minute of it oh I'm so happy thank you
so much